hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for numb Monday November 20th 2017 right
off the bat the first thing you should
notice is my hushed [ __ ] tone not a
hushed tone a hushed [ __ ] tone my
daughter is sleeping downstairs like
5:30 in the [ __ ] morning and it's the
only time we're gonna have to do this
podcast if I wanted to kind of come out
on time today so that is what I'm doing
I was with my daughter all day yesterday
was awesome Nia went out with some
friends and then she went out to [ __ ]
dinner and I just sat there we watched
the Patriots Raiders I had taped the
Celtics Hawks game I watched a little
bit of the Dallas Philly game cuz on
inside the NFL I said Dallas was gonna
win
and my only reasoning was division
rivalries you know what I mean it's like
look how bad the Buffalo Bills got
[ __ ] raped yesterday by the San Diego
Chargers for whatever [ __ ] reason
they're gonna give us a tough game
they're at least gonna cover the spread
one goddamn time for the simple fact
that we see him twice a year going back
to like 1960 back in the AFL you know so
I was wrong I'm big enough to say that I
was wrong
Carson went I guess six foot five
unbelievably mobile bet Eagles put a
thumping on I'm a big enough man to say
I was wrong I'm a big enough man just
let you know that I'm sitting here
drinking tea all alone so yeah I just
did that was just uh hanging out with my
daughter dude she's amazing she really
is amazing she's like all over the place
you can say mama now
and she can say Dada but she doesn't
know what they mean you know and she
doesn't know when the word ends so you
like say mama she just goes mama mama
mama
say Dada jogo like mama mama come on say
Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada and
then pointing myself so just smile at me
like the [ __ ] is with you and she just
crawls away she could stand she can let
go with stuff still stand for good like
I don't know I think it records like
eight or nine seconds and you always
think that they're gonna like fall back
and hit the head drives you nuts but
some reason they just sit right down in
there but I don't know I still don't
trust the whole I still don't trust the
whole thing and I did the classic Dada
moments almost but somebody bought us a
toy that I think is a little advanced
for my kid and it was basically you know
like the walkers that old people have
this is like the same kind of thing
except it's you know it has a smiling
cows face on it and sing songs on the
front but essentially it's an old person
walker so my daughter was pushing it
around like her knees first and then she
started standing up what I did was I put
my iPhone slightly in front of it you
know because they love any sort of
computer screen and she was you know
started taking steps with it or anything
but there's like no break on it it's
like really [ __ ] dangerous so I
always have to be hovering over so the
one time I go to film er doing it and no
I'm not going to show you this footage
she [ __ ] starts to walk and I'm
filming her and all of a sudden she like
leaned back and the whole thing like
tipped over on and she fell down hit her
head she was on the rugs off the capita
area but if I were to show you that
video you'd see the second she was in
danger
I [ __ ] threw the camera down I tried
to catch her as opposed to most of these
[ __ ] parents out there I swear to god
it's like they're trying to put him in
bad positions and then the kid falls
down and he had the parents laughing
they don't even try to help him cuz it
all giddy thinking like this is gonna
get me a bunch of hits like I haven't
seen this one there's some kid I guess
somebody was telling me
like hanging from something and falls
into a [ __ ] fish tank breaks the fish
tank or something that's water that's
glass
that's dead fish that's the kind of [ __ ]
used to get you sent to bed the second
your parents saw it they really do what
the [ __ ] are you doing okay they didn't
say dude
but everything else they said now the
parents just sit there and they you know
it's like watching one of those nature
shows like anytime they show a snake
eating somehow it always finds a [ __ ]
mouse Dana long you'd have to sit there
following that goddamned snake around
with an entire camera crew the thing
keeps turning around looking at you're
trying to strike you you freaking it out
right bless you and your camera crew
making all that goddamn noise you're
gonna scare all the mice away but
somehow they always seem to capture the
moment the snake fights the other snake
you know it kills a rabbit it kills a
[ __ ] bird I want to know why all of
these [ __ ] people out there right
all of these animal lovers they're
talking about the Japanese beating all
those dolphins to death in the cove
they're talking about don't leave your
dog you know in a in a car with the
windows up all of that [ __ ] what about
these mice okay on these these these
[ __ ] nature shows I think I've told
this before I watched one one time
they're following this snake through
them will say aircore woods
okay the snake is completely oblivious
of the goddamn camera crew they must be
just tippy-toeing around right craft
services just off in the distance you
know so they got one camera team is
following this mouse the other team is
following like this rattlesnake or
something so the mouse goes down into
the hole and then the snakes goes down
in the hole and then next thing you know
I'm in the hole to the camera he's in
like the giant living room part the open
area at the great room the room over the
garage if you will of this hole
okay the game room the man cave right
and the cameras already in there the
[ __ ] mouse is staying in there like
what the [ __ ]
you know like Joe Pesci in Goodfellas
like ah now the second it sees the
camera and then the snake comes in and
kills the thing I want to know PETA
they're so busy you know wrapping
themselves around some [ __ ] half-dead
armadillo laman in the streets where the
[ __ ] are they on this issue how in God's
name could that camera crew possibly and
all the [ __ ] holes in the woods of
all the [ __ ] mice in the gather mice
in the woods I don't know
right of all the [ __ ] rodents in the
goddamn woods how the hell did they know
that this [ __ ] Mouse was gonna go
down that [ __ ] hole and that snake
that they were following was gonna
follow that mouse down into that hole
into that part of the hole there's only
one way people it was a setup okay set
up the same way they set up those sharks
to look like a bunch of lunatics when
they hang that [ __ ] steamship around
hanging off the goddamn boat steamship
round everybody I told you I'd working
in just basically half the hind quarters
of a cow they got that hanging off the
side of the boat right the great white
shark shows up it's got that our sin eel
thing where you know when it smiles it
shows way too much gums making it not a
sympathetic character which is why I
think when they brought our senio back
it didn't last that long I think
personally I don't think it was cause of
the talent of the man you know go back
and watch coming to America going blow
for blow with Eddie Murphy you know same
thing with these great white sharks
majestic beautiful doing their [ __ ]
job
god forbid you got crooked teeth in
America telling you the mice have
crooked teeth they got pointy teeth
right are they meat-eaters
the [ __ ] does a mouse eat it's gotta be
it's gotta suck when you figure out that
in the pecking order of nature you're
just sort of this like a slider you like
this appetizer like this is you know all
of that sha Christ a [ __ ] like
rabbits it's like rabbits have to
produce the way they do or a bunch of
other species die and I imagine some
egghead with the lab coat would say that
eventually human beings would die unless
we ate a plant-based diet fruits and
vegetables grains and nuts I'll get into
this [ __ ] later on you know I watched
this video saying that you know meat and
butter and [ __ ] and eggs and dairy
wasn't that bad so you know what happens
the second you [ __ ] say that uh you
know this food isn't bad
a bunch of people other non-experts
come out of the [ __ ] woodwork and
start telling you about the videos that
they that they just watched and the [ __ ]
that they think is right you know it's
literally like these [ __ ] food people
and nutrition people I'm done with them
you know what they're like they're like
religious people where they think God
loves them best their story about God
Buddha Muhammad Jesus you know JT right
I don't want to start a race war here if
not a race war a religious war here but
you got to MIT Jesus is the coolest out
of all of them you know hey man like I I
just want to see me walk on water I mean
just doing all these tricks right he's
like a [ __ ] lounge act in Vegas he's
pulling all the [ __ ] bread and the
fish out you know in fairness to
Muhammad I have not read one word about
him I've never read the Quran I've never
even read the Bible you know in the
afterlife I just hope I die in a group
accident you don't I mean so that way
we're all just kind of sitting there I
can kind of skate with the smart kids
you know when the teacher were coming
did anybody read the short story last
night y'all read it and everybody's kind
of like yeah you like try not to make
eye contact then do but start asking
questions you like out [ __ ] come on man
you start looking at the smart kid like
dude put your [ __ ] hand up and ask
God you answer these [ __ ] questions
this is my afterlife things gonna be
about you know I actually don't think
it's gonna be that bad because I am a
big believer that either you're just
dead like that poor [ __ ] Mouse oh the
Arsenio Hall rebooted the talk show
she's dead now [ __ ] that he's like my
daughter up I can hear her downstairs
but she always wakes up this time
anyways it's amazing when you're a
parent the second you kid stirs in the
crib you [ __ ] wake up we're still not
getting eat I was sleep probably I'm
talking about this [ __ ] Mouse right
now 547 in the morning Pacific Coast
time yeah I think either you're dead or
you just kind of show up and gods just
like yeah sorry about that you know it's
just a big experiment I just you know I
wanted to create a bunch of things that
destroy each other I mean that's what
happens if you do watch those nature
shows the level of [ __ ] murder that
goes on out in nature just all the time
does anybody die of old age like died a
natural death
in nature I think like elephants do but
even then they're trying to walk back to
that place that they remember and and
although he's hyping up elephants but
everything that they [ __ ] remember
it's like I get it I get it they're
smart okay I get it there's 30,000
[ __ ] muscles and their goddamn nose
I'm just [ __ ] with you you got a love
element elephants
you know rhinos and hippos are the [ __ ]
of elephants you know what I mean I can
feel like an elephant you kind of got a
shot as long as that kids not around
like an elephant just kind of looks over
it yeah it's just like I meant you know
keep you keep you distance everything's
[ __ ] cool and rhinos in like
hippopotamuses those [ __ ] things or
uh did I say rhinos and elephants are
the cuts of the elephants that I said
earlier did I say rhinos and hippos I
don't even know it's [ __ ] it early
rhinos and hippos are the [ __ ] of
elephants you know what I mean
little short [ __ ] they didn't
get the long nose right just one of
those guys coming out playing pick-up
hockey a pick-up hoop and just taking it
way too seriously
and you just instinctively try to stay
away from them before they blow your
[ __ ] knee out ever watch one of those
animal videos one like the hippo is like
chasing after the boat going under the
water coming out of the water come on
under the water coming out of the water
it's like how the [ __ ] is it producing
that speed it's a tub of [ __ ] it's got a
giant [ __ ] head it's not aerodynamic
whatsoever and it's got those little
short legs I think it's doing the
butterfly it's definitely not doggy
paddling when it gets going it's got to
be doing the butterfly it's got to be
front legs forward you know and then
both legs at the same time and then
thrust and back like a hippos like that
fat kid at the pool who won't always
goes into the pool with this shirt on
right the fat kid in the [ __ ] red
head like me I don't know why I never
thought to do that I would just take the
[ __ ] sunburn it's gonna turn into
colour later is it bill that are skin
cancer anyways how about those New
England Patriots number one offense and
the lowest-rated defense I don't know
about you guys but I think that spells
success in January
I'd have to look at the numbers and see
how just see how they've been doing all
over the last if the last few weeks if
they've been letting up less points
you know like God knows we got the [ __ ]
kicked out of us not even it was just
the final quarter and a half we get the
[ __ ] kicked out of us by the Kansas City
Chiefs okay and everyone was going like
holy [ __ ] Brady is old
here comes Kansas City and now look what
happened Kansas City just lost to the
[ __ ] New York Giants the lowly New
York Giants whoever thought you would
say that all right
Patriots schedule results yeah 2014
that's what I want to [ __ ] say 2017
dude what what what God's name is going
on the health scores are these all right
here we go what the hell's going on with
Kansas City like how many [ __ ] times
can you do this to your fan base how
many times can you get these [ __ ]
people excited only to turn around and
just [ __ ] the bed I don't understand it
all right preseason preseason preseason
all right we gave up 42 points to the
Jets then we gave up 20 points to the
Saints 33 to the Texans 33 to the
Panthers 14 to the Buccaneers 17 to the
Jets seven to the Falcons 13 to the
Chargers Iowa doing all right here 16 to
the Broncos but they stink and eight to
the Raiders all right I think we're all
right then I thought I overheard that
stat yesterday that we were last in team
defense it's nice to actually see us get
pressure on the quarterback I felt bad
for Derek Carr though Jesus Christ I
don't know if the the Raiders have been
dropping as many passes as Tony Romo was
suggested but how great is Tony Romo in
the broadcast booth
the guy knows the game and he's not
afraid to [ __ ] on people I love it
I feel like he's doing everything that
people think Chris Collinsworth is doing
and Chris Collinsworth I thought was
always fair all day right now the
Patriots are just not getting it done a
defense like I always felt like as much
as it was annoying to hear like I know
Chris I'm watching the game he can't get
mad cos the guys right on the other hand
Tony Romo just takes shots that guy's as
[ __ ] hilarious like when they was
sitting there saying how Tom Brady is
the only player to ever throw a
touchdown pass in three different
countries being the United States of
America England and now Mexico so Tony
Romo goes yeah you know what that means
he's a great quarterback and he's really
old you know what I loved about that it
was funny listening to somebody make fun
of Tom Brady and then it was also funny
knowing that you could just hear Tony
Romo bitching to his girlfriend about
how much attention [ __ ] Tom Brady was
getting you know to me as he was trying
to be a Dallas Cowboy quarterback which
God knows you know there's no [ __ ] I
don't know what whatever whatever no
good deed goes unpunished when you're a
quarterback for that team forget the
fact that Tony Romo had like 11
quarterback coaches in like 10 seasons
or whatever followed along he was there
you know I bet he was just going like oh
you know every [ __ ] thing I do in
this [ __ ] one-horse goddamn town that
thinks that this giant City just gets
scrutinise oh but Tom Brady yeah we so
[ __ ] good-looking hey I'm just as
good-looking as that guy right you know
he's thinking all of that [ __ ] so it's
fun listening to [ __ ] on people I
thought it was funny when he made fun of
Deion Sanders and that Deion Sanders who
was so above the conversation took the
time to [ __ ] on him back
I enjoy all of that anyways I ain't by
the way how greet with a Mexican fans by
the way you know I know a lot of
Americans flew down there well I guess
we're all Americans right we're all part
of North America all people from the
United States of the Americas flew down
for those games but and the Raiders of
the perfect team down there if I wasn't
mistaken I thought I heard the Patriots
getting booed down there which made me
feel great nice to know we get respect
down there too and I don't know I
thought it was a great game I am a
little concerned though considering we
lost Andrews our Center and then we Nick
not Nick Cannon Marcus cannon is out and
then the back up to Marcus can and also
has gone down so I don't know who the
[ __ ] we play next week but uh I'll tell
you right now these Patriots their
offensive line better get healthier
that's gonna spell nothing but trouble
come January hang on it's my daughter
still chases Christ
they can waking her up she still
downstairs making noise I gotta talk
even quieter I'm sorry I'll turn up the
volume I'll turn everything up there we
go
why don't you use the volume bill to
your [ __ ] advantage all right I'm
gonna whisper for the rest of this I
swear to God the first whispered podcast
ever I'm not gonna do that to you
alright I wouldn't I would never do that
deep alright let's talk about some more
[ __ ] i watch my first Bruins game in
my in a half of two Celtics games for
the first time this year first of all
who are these 2017 2018 Boston Celtics I
barely recognize to anybody's face but I
can tell you this is we're [ __ ] young
as [ __ ] okay
we can't Jason Tatum Mike it's like
[ __ ] 20 years old
we got Brown who I think they were
seeing is 20 years old that's not
starting our starting five
we got a Horford you know he's like the
Cedeno Chara of the team we got Marcus
smart he's still on the team and how
long the [ __ ] else we got some other guy
in there and all I know is we beat the
Golden State [ __ ] Warriors in and
they barely scored any points against us
I figure what the final score was but
like both teams were like in the [ __ ]
80s
anyways all I know if it was under a
hundred we made the Warriors play our
game and we slowed it down okay and God
knows if you can beat the Golden State
Warriors in November what's gonna happen
come January I'll tell you right now the
Celtics won one game against the
Warriors does this mean they're gonna
sweep them in a seven-game series
they're gonna start doing that [ __ ] I
obviously think the Warriors are still
too strong I think we I think we have a
better head coach and Brad Stevens but I
also think we still have to get past
LeBron James and the Cavaliers but first
I just said I forget who the other guy
was it's a guy from the [ __ ] trade
there with the plastic mask Kyrie Irving
I'm very excited to watch them I watched
my first Bruins game and this year and I
watched the stinkeroo against the
[ __ ] Anaheim Mighty Ducks I think we
beat the Kings the next night and I
missed the game against the San Jose
Sharks but I think Brad Marchand is
coming back but we're pretty pretty
banged up right now whatever it's good
to be banged up this time of year rather
than the end of the year cuz that's when
you play for the trophy there sorry I'm
listen I think she went back to sleep
alright cool
Jesus Christ how much quieter can you
[ __ ] talk it's damn kids I swear to
god they spoiled brats this spoiled
brats do what the [ __ ] is going on with
the Kansas City Chiefs I don't get these
guys I just don't get it now the Saints
are coming on but when the saints come
marchin and they got [ __ ] Drew Brees
and they have a running game I actually
[ __ ] looked up yesterday um my
daughter fell asleep on my chest right
and it's just like I Ricky move rookie
move I should've had a fall asleep on
the bed and then I could have got up and
got on with my life for [ __ ] 50 to 90
minutes says she's sleeping on my chest
I'm just like well how do i how do I
make this time productive and I realized
I'm inside the NFL how little I know
about the players in the league I mean I
was already working too hard on f is for
family and I got the kid I barely know
anybody so I started looking up and the
starting quarterbacks of every team
trying to see how many I could name
alright so here we go I swear to god I
don't have him in front of me I would
try to remember as many as I can okay
Tom Brady the greatest of all time up
there in New England playing in
Foxborough and he got Tyrod Taylor and
Buffalo I don't give a [ __ ] who his
backup is I'm not gonna waste my time
memorizing a backups [ __ ] name
alright until until they
do something till they win the [ __ ]
job the Jets have Josh McCown Eli
Manning the Patriot killer the Eagles
got who
Carson Wentz and then the alias Joe
Flacco the name he give to the cops
what's your name Joe Joe what Joe Flacco
now then who the [ __ ] to the Redskins
have you like that you like that
whatever his [ __ ] name is there's
like 20 Carson's I feel he's another guy
with this C name and it's not cont Cam
Newton then Jacksonville has Blake
bortles Jameson Winston and Tampa Bay
and then Jay Cutler Matty ice in Atlanta
Drew Brees at the Saints Marcus
Merriweather is it [ __ ] the Titans I
couldn't name it he's I just [ __ ]
tried I'm trying to test my [ __ ]
brain here all right then you go to the
Bengals you got the [ __ ] the red head
there all right the giant ginger Andy
Dalton with the [ __ ] hipster haircut
mocking my hairline and then the Browns
one of the great names and of all sports
have DeSean Kaiser I love that name is
he a black guy is is is he [ __ ]
celebrating Hitler's birthday you don't
know I don't know Kaiser just sounds
like a [ __ ] German officer to me I
don't know why all right and what do you
got you got that guy out there to the
Lions what the [ __ ] his name Tommy
Hilfiger I don't know why that name just
popped in my head my mom is one of the
best could Eric Hipple
the [ __ ] do they have I just went blank
on his name Andrew Luck is with
Indianapolis I
they got that dude from NC State backing
him up Aaron Rodgers I know he's hurt my
ribs still feel why he's hurt I don't
know who the Vikings have the Bears have
some guy Mitchell [ __ ] true Biscay or
some [ __ ] thing Alex Smith Zach
Prescott the [ __ ] Texans who the [ __ ]
do they got I know there's some fantasy
football people just rattling off they
got that kid from Clemson who got hurt
and then Denver I always forget that
guy's name it's some regular name and
his last name is like [ __ ]
Oscillation or some [ __ ] I don't know
who the [ __ ] Cardinals have the LA
Rams have the [ __ ] is his name Jared
Goff Phillip Rivers Derek Carr and then
this one killed me CJ beat hard jackoff
murder you meet whatever his [ __ ]
last name is and then he got Russell
Wilson see that's not bad that wasn't
bad now I asked me to name all the
receivers I can't name anybody that's
what I knew I realized I wasn't inside
the NFL that I'm gonna bore you guys to
death trying to [ __ ] get caught back
up you don't [ __ ] me over
is when I stop collecting football cards
I'd love to get back into it but they
won't do they won't just let you buy a
whole set you know at least they
wouldn't last time I tried to collect
like ten years ago I think I'm gonna
have to give in and start playing
fantasy football no I'm just not gonna
know anybody all right I mean you just
promote some things here I'm doing a
benefit tonight at the Laugh Factory in
Long Beach if you want to come down and
watch me do a headlining set and a
wonderful comedy club and watch all of
the money go to go to the victims of the
hurricane out there in Puerto Rico
please come down there's some tickets
left all right that club has not been
doing the greatest job promoting this
[ __ ] show
all right so please come down I'll do a
meet-and-greet afterwards I'll shake
your hand I'll sign your [ __ ] tits
whatever the hell you want me to do but
I'll ask you first before I sign your
tits before I get in trouble oh also
Jesus Christ oh all things comedy we got
our new website up redesigned it and all
that type of stuff I couldn't find the
TV shows that we've made yet those
things should be coming up soon too so
please check that out all things comedy
comm and now for some sad news I even
sat just an amazing life Malcolm young
of ac/dc passed away and all the
football I watched just seeing the NFL I
was a little perturbed I was a little
annoyed that there wasn't any sort of
tribute to Malcolm young considering
he's arguably the greatest rock and roll
rhythm guitarist of all time he's
written so many classic riffs all of
those ac/dc albums and there's like four
or five that are just absolute
masterpieces they're all great but he
has five [ __ ] masterpieces all right
as much as I love Pink Floyd as much as
I love Led Zeppelin I mean they're right
there with them masterpiece highway to
hell masterpiece back in black
masterpiece let the be rock masterpiece
powerage masterpiece flick of the switch
masterpiece all right and if you don't
[ __ ] think they are it's cuz you're
not you don't know what you know you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
I even like for those about to rock
everybody was all [ __ ] losers grutas
back in black and shut the [ __ ] up
anyways I would have thought the NFL
would have done something for how many
years that they've been playing hells
bells and thunderstruck and all that
getting their stadiums all amped up and
how many years did his band you know
then come back on tour and sell out
those same football stadiums how much
money has the NFL
you know that's a great partnership that
I made off of that band and during the
offseason when they try to have soccer
in their stadiums and the [ __ ] place
is half full who comes in to save the
day
[ __ ] Malcolm young with his band
ac/dc and some of the greatest riffs of
all [ __ ] time you know I was lucky
enough to see him how many times I see
him I think I saw him three times I saw
him in 86 on the who made who tour on
the Heat secret tour I saw his nephew
who's now in the band then I saw them
all I think I only saw him twice then I
saw him on black ice I've seen ac/dc
three times then I saw him on the Black
Ice tour that was the last time I saw
him and he's just the coolest greatest
yeah rock and roll rhythm guitarist of
all time just the way they would they
build a song I was listening to livewire
you know only he could just make those
chords sound so [ __ ] evil and the way
he builds him it it still gives me
chills TNT I don't know if there's just
too many overdose the way that song
builds I know everybody knows the
classics gon shootin the whole second
side of powerage down payment blues all
of that stuff it's just absolute giant I
don't know I thought did Google do a
tribute to him I mean that's the level
of guy that passed away here but anyways
thanks to him and his genius and that
unbelievable that was my band
growing up I was actually laughs and
listened to all that music I wasn't
really even like sad that he was gone
because I think he lives like such an
amazing life and I was just thinking of
all the [ __ ] classes that I flunked
in high school and how depressed I was
how stupid I thought I was and then I
would just go out and I would [ __ ]
get in my piece of [ __ ] truck
and I would turn it on a pop and that
cassette and then I would just go into
fantasy world that I was in that band
and knew how to play guitar then I would
instantly be in a good mood again and I
used to always sing on multiple-choice
tests that I knew I was flunking and I
was just guessing and I was running out
of time that Bon Scott lyric I don't
remember what song is from that take a
chance why you still got two choice rock
and roll damnation that song would be
playing in a loop as I was guessing I
forget what I got on my se SATs but I
got like a 300 something combined and
I'm gonna tell you I tried I took a prep
course I did everything and I just
[ __ ] [ __ ] the bed on it and I'd love
to tell you people that had had a major
effect on my life but it didn't anyways
let's read some so rest in peace Malcolm
young there's never gonna be another one
like you that's it him I always thought
he always thought he Malcolm young and
Phil Rudd with the two coolest guys in
the bin that was it right there those
two [ __ ] guys Malcolm and Phil Rudd
sitting there with the cigarette
dangling out of his mouth just [ __ ]
crushing it I think even Billy Joel said
you know that was the greatest live band
he's ever seen speaking of which does
anybody hear the Howard Stern interview
with Billy Joel she's [ __ ] amazing
what a talent there's a guy I have to go
see live I can't believe I never seen
that guy live
I was such a douche in the 80s if you
didn't have a guitar I just thought you
were the biggest [ __ ] ever a [ __ ]
watch this guy playing his piano your
parents pay for that [ __ ] your
recital meanwhile he's his total badass
I never understood such a bad thing to
say but I never realized how talented
and what a badass Billy Joel was I
honestly didn't really pay attention to
the guy instantly started getting
hammered driving his car into the
[ __ ] fronts of people's houses you
know I meant when he was singing like
uptown girl and all that type of [ __ ]
when I was an uptown girl what was that
song or one of those songs where he was
singing like you know he was in love
with this girl across the tracks like he
was this badass guy she's like told you
this little Jewish guy playing [ __ ]
piano yeah that's about as safe as it
gets you you're a model citizen that's
what I thought I didn't realize that he
starts getting hammered driving his car
into people's houses and this is just
trying to sit down and eat dinner and I
was like oh you know what I guess he is
from the other side of the tracks gotta
love a boozehound all right speaking of
which I'm 95 miserable days in you know
I was hanging out with these two
alcoholics this [ __ ] weekend who are
now clean and they are both sitting
there going yeah you know I don't miss
it I don't miss it I was just like oh
yeah
I do I do you know all right oh look
who's here have you buddy a little zip
[Music]
all right simple crew to everybody are
you hiring well are you do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates talk about the satisfaction
of employing it actually is a great it
is a great feeling when you hire
somebody you know knowing that you put a
fellow American to work right knowing
you can tell them what they what they
can and can't do
knowing you can lord over them with zip
recruiter knowing you can ruin their
holidays with one simple phone call and
two of the best words in the English
language you're fired
with zip recruiter you can post your job
to over 100 of the webs of leading job
boards with just one click so you can
rest easy knowing your job is being seen
by the right candidates due to how
creepy is this copy when I'm whispering
then sip
recruiting I'm like that creep at work
coming up behind you in your cubicle are
you doing this weekend
then zip recruiter puts its mad matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job
within minutes of posting so you receive
the best possible matches that's why the
zip recruiter is different it's just
different and it's okay with it unlike
other hiring sites zip recruiter doesn't
depend on the right candidates finding
you it finds them you can even get a
head start on the interview process by
adding screening questions to your job
oh sorry I was checking out what time it
is to see if I still have time to do
cardio before you get on with my day
that's so exciting this copyists you can
even get a head start on in the
interview process by adding screen
questions to your job post to help
identify the most qualified candidates
yeah do you have a sex scandal in your
past so you don't have to waste time
sorting through a stack of resumes to
find the perfect fit this guy's
perfectly the job oh my god he [ __ ] a
cat move on to the next one no wonder
80% of the employees who post on zip
recruiter get a qualified candidate
through the site in just one day and the
easy-to-use zip recruiter dashboard lets
you manage your hiring process from
start to finish all in one place
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
find out today why is it as you has been
used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find out the most
qualified job candidates with the
media's immediate results in right now
my listeners can post their job on zip
recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruitni.com / / that's
it / / one more time Jesus Christ try it
one more time for free go to zip
recruiting home / / wow that was way too
[ __ ] long enough is it I just feel
like poor mwah
all right he likes sleep everybody he
looks hellix there are a ton of online
mass mattress retailers popping up these
days are there I have no idea all with a
one-size-fits-all solution to a better
sleep guess what one size doesn't fit
all
okay some people have a round ass
somebody have a flat ass some people
have long legs right some people have
abnormally big earlobes
now you wouldn't think that all this
plays a factor in a comfortable good
night's sleep but I'm here to tell you
different helix sleep offers something
that doesn't exist anywhere else a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that
won't set you back thousands of dollars
what exactly is a [ __ ] sleeping style
huh do you sleep reverse cowgirl like
you're [ __ ] possessed can you imagine
that imagine if you [ __ ] married the
most beautiful woman in the world and
she just sat she slept sitting up in bed
like you'd go to sleep like goodnight
honey and she would be laying back in
the middle of the night you just you
know that [ __ ] instinct you have that
should I open my eyes right now
and you open your eyes and you look over
and she was sitting up in bed [ __ ]
sleeping you imagine the first night you
reach over and touch her on her shoulder
like hey honey
right what if she slept sitting up with
her eyes open built what if you finished
reading this coffee alright go to helix
sleep calm slash bird take their simple
two to three minutes sleep quiz they'll
build a custom mattress that would be
the best thing you've ever slept on for
couples they even personalize each side
of the mattress which is the beginning
of the end of the relationship I just
feel like we're not connecting anymore
yeah if she's if she sat up sleeping she
didn't like the craftmatic bed on her
side your custom mattress arriving from
GQ to cosmic from Cosmopolitan to the
New York
are all talking about HELOCs yeah
because you paying them that's why I'm
talking about it and once you try it out
you'll know why your custom mattress
arrives direct to your door in a week
and shipping is completely free try it
for a hundred nights if gross if you
don't love it they'll pick it up and
refund you in full oh my god yeah
mr. white and Jesse Pinkman show up in
their hazmat suits and they take it back
Ct a must-read hey HELOCs and i'll wait
whatever the [ __ ] I want to read go to
helix sleep comp slash bar right now and
you'll get $50 towards your custom
mattress that's HELOCs sleep calm slash
bar for $50 off your order
helix sleep Cobb slash burn all right
the last one thank Christ movement
watches em VMT watches pronounced
movement was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank we get a
holiday shopping can we get a holiday
shopping can't be tough this is where
they try to be down-to-earth but thanks
to MVM t all that gift giving anxiety
can disappear with the press of a button
these watches make the perfect purchase
for just about anyone in your life guy
or girl and remember they started only
$95.00 you know I just realized I have
the volume turn up so high and they have
to have the microphone so close to my
mouth I hope I don't sound like a
mealy-mouthed jackass here and if I do I
don't
well I guess I give a [ __ ] out when I
brought it up huh you know I do we go
let me finish this here all right you've
heard me talk about movement wait these
watches make the perfect purchase for
just about anyone in your life guy or
girl and remember they started in 95
bucks that's not chump change you know
but for a good watch that's pretty good
you've heard me talk about MVM T and I
am sure you got yourself a watch now
let's finish your hop your holiday
shopping and get a MVM T watch for
someone on your list the holiday
shopping season is here yes we realize
this this is why you
about the holidays with MVM tea you can
skip the crowds and standing in crazy
lines and find a gift they'll love at
prices that beat department stores at
such great prices moving watches make a
wonderful holiday gift to classic design
quality construction styled and styled
minimalism get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement watches comm / / go-to movement
watches calm / bird join the movement
alright that's it okay let's get into
the questions here for this week I
really apologize for the [ __ ]
whispering but what do you already want
from me alright Malcolm everybody bill
if you read this please refer to me as
Steve okay Steve reads I don't know why
I'll never understand why my friends
gave me such a hard time for attending
the ACDC show in Madison Wisconsin in
2001 being a high school sophomore ac/dc
with his [ __ ] as far as I was concerned
but at the same time I didn't give a
[ __ ] about top for him and let my
classmates know they had [ __ ] taste
ac/dc never let up the most hard-working
band of the last 30 years they never let
down their fans
I just queued up if you want blood
oh what a [ __ ] song that is the drums
are insane and that perfect [ __ ] drum
beat
everything is just this [ __ ] he said
there's nothing better Oh unless you're
talking about the live album it's
another amazing thing when I actually
went to Glasgow Scotland I looked up the
theater because I wanted to go in there
where they've recorded then thing
doesn't exist anymore anyways wanted to
keep this short
hope you're well you freckled [ __ ]
alright I don't know what you didn't
really ask a question but I share your
opinions on ac/dc and I've already
talked about that Shh it alright alright
front-flipping robot I actually saw that
hey there Billy mm did you see the video
of the extremely agile robot that was
going around last week yeah it was kind
of look like a white dude doing flips
okay
man build this thing is legit it's the
first robot machine that I've ever seen
where I thought
I cannot disarm my co yeah it's total
Robocop even with the extreme flames are
large amount of water I think it could
kill me first
you're right about all this robot [ __ ]
no one is going to be scared enough to
stop this also if we didn't make robots
that could fight wouldn't we just be
sending our guys in to wait also if we
didn't make robots second fight when we
just be sending our guys in to fight
Russian or Chinese robots now you just
want the exact opposite way yeah this is
how human beings we out of fear and just
the seduction of power we just keep
making these [ __ ] things it would be
great if somehow we could all just get
on the same page you know so we wouldn't
do this type of [ __ ] to each other cuz
this is the it's not it's not gonna
[ __ ] in well it really isn't but
we're never gonna get on the same page
oh so I you know when I do I just sort
of give in to the fact that we're doomed
to destroy ourselves all right and I
have to think a robot death has to be a
quick death I would like to think that
the Illuminati who is making these
things to replace all of us because they
totally fit the belt for everything the
illuminati wants which is basically
slaves do what we say do whatever we say
whenever we say it and what have we said
for years like [ __ ] we like what did
we [ __ ] robots and what are the
Illuminati doing robots
hmm and it went out they made the
[ __ ] things I just want to talk to
all the nerds out there and everybody
who thinks these nerds are harmless
these are [ __ ] [ __ ] egghead nerds
who are so [ __ ] smart that they are
going to destroy us because they are
listening to the [ __ ] sociopaths of
society the people boring power
and they go out and they make these
[ __ ] things for them you stupid nerd
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean what do you do if
your health capped it by a robot you
just have to wait to the thing powers
down and just hope you can find a
screwdriver and just start unscrewing
[ __ ] and just [ __ ] ripping out wires
but you know what they're gonna do
they're gonna make these robots like the
ones that are designed to kill all of us
they're gonna make him odd I like the
same material as that door on the
cockpit of a plane that nobody can get
into that's what it's gonna be unless
you have the codes man yeah that's all
that's all scary [ __ ] and back when I
was just a [ __ ] guy who was married
and I didn't have a kid it wasn't as
scary because I was already thinking
like you know what I've had a great
[ __ ] life I really have I've done all
kinds of stuff I got to made a dream
come true becoming a comedian everything
else has been gravy I got a great wife
this is the kind of [ __ ] that I think
that when I see robots I'm like you know
I've had a great life that thing comes
in and just grabs you by throat just
crushes my [ __ ] windpipe that's what
I'm gonna be thinking I'm gonna be
thinking this robot as much as it's
killing me right now is never gonna know
joy it's just gonna no inputs anyways
that's what i'ma say to the robot yeah
at least I know what happiness feels
like robot gets all mad shut the [ __ ] up
but if it could feel anger then I could
feel joy all right sorry okay MMP advice
a lady requests your advice on men okay
hi Bill how are you I love you work
especially your specials and your mmm
podcast advice I learned a lot from your
advice about the male point of view
that's really [ __ ] I feel like
there's a lot of layers to that
compliment and I would be grateful for
your insight all right
I don't know why you're listening to me
but okay
we go I have no [ __ ] background
whatsoever other than failing a lot
alright no professional background I am
a happily married woman with the toddler
baby girl isn't that the best and I'm
currently pregnant with another girl
he hit the lottery twice I am writing
you I'm writing to you because by
listening to it seems that in general
you feel that women have the upper hand
in life however I disagree well yeah the
grass is always greener sweetheart that
is one thing that I always I do as
feminist I say to them is there any
scenario is there even one scenario
where you can think that hey I'm you
know as far as men and women go in this
scenario it's good to be a woman they
can't do that because their whole
business model falls to the [ __ ]
ground
every [ __ ] scenario it's so much
harder for us is it everything out there
is harder for a woman then why do you
outlive us if your life is really that
much more difficult than mine why do you
outlive a man on average by like eight
to [ __ ] 10 years let me guess
because the man is doing something wrong
blame the victim ladies the exact thing
you don't want done to yourself you ever
think that maybe you have a something to
do with it here's a classic one you know
when my wife leaves the house you know
what I think I think cool I got the
house to myself right when I leave the
house you know what my wife thinks
what can i him and tell him to go out
and go get me what can I add he's out
there having fun let me add a [ __ ]
air into it hey can you go to Trader
Joe's could you just go to Trader Joe's
really quickly this Saturday before
Thanksgiving and wade into that [ __ ]
Black Friday food [ __ ] mosh pit sorry
that was my yesterday anyways I disagree
I think men have the upper hand in
general especially when it comes to job
prospects salary and sexual
aggressions out Jesus Christ here we go
again what is sexual aggressions mean I
don't even know what the [ __ ] that means
I would agree with job prospects and
salary but I think the biggest [ __ ]
problem women have is you guys don't go
out and start enough businesses you keep
coming
working for men we've been [ __ ] you
over since day one at what point are you
gonna become self-sufficient and I feel
like I'm not just [ __ ] going I'm not
like being like do as I say not as I do
that's what I did in this business I am
self-sufficient in this business if this
business took everything away from me I
can still be a stand-up comedian and do
my podcast
I'm completely self-employed those two
things make me the most amount of money
and I can easily live off either of
those I got a TV show I have a cartoon
called emphasis of family but I was
never dumb enough to be like well I got
a TV show now and quit stand-up comedy
like I saw so many comedians do because
eventually your show goes off the air
and those [ __ ] residual checks to
whittle down to like you know I get
residual checks routinely for like under
$3 so I'm trying to say this to empower
you but you know quit your [ __ ]
whining alright there's all these
studies out there they clearly show that
women are smarter than men so if you're
smarter than us then you can build a
better mousetrap so get together with
some of your smart lady friends and
start a [ __ ] business but for the
love of God quit your [ __ ] whining
everybody out there is eating a giant
[ __ ] sandwich now granted there might be
less [ __ ] in my sandwich than yours but
make no mistake it's still a [ __ ]
sandwich alright but there's nothing
stopping you from picking out the bread
because when you do start your own
business you're gonna work more than you
ever worked that whole thing where it's
like I will start my business and then I
will delegate and it will run on its own
and I'll sit on a [ __ ] yacht yeah and
they will rob you blind
anyways sexual aggressions alright but
you I think you guys make up more than
make up for sexual aggressions
whatever the [ __ ] that means is that
sexual assault are we talking about
we're the ones who have to have an
opening line I think you guys more than
make it up with divorce court
aggressions okay and your whole [ __ ]
thing where you know I wish that women
could just beat the [ __ ] out of guys
instead of just taking every [ __ ]
because an ass-kicking it's like you
know a week of epson salt you go to the
dentist you can put it behind you
alright but when a woman kick should
kick your ass it just you know they just
take everything everything the house the
kids you Qatar Collection your car
whatever the [ __ ] you collect that you
love they're gonna make you sell that
not even cuz they need the [ __ ] money
just cuz they know it's gonna put
another [ __ ] hole in your heart
alright so there you go so here we go
manic [ __ ] play my little violin as I
listen to the rest this I agree with
George Carlin my hero when he said 99%
of all the truly horrifying [ __ ] going
on in this world was initiated
established perpetrated enabled or
continued by men yeah absolutely but
that's only because women haven't been
given an opportunity to show how [ __ ]
out of their minds they are I gotta be
honest with you I don't understand why
to compliment a woman you have two trash
men anyways he says and in the course of
life's compared with men women have far
more to put up with they bear greater
burdens extra spoonfuls
[ __ ] hello boy
I don't 100% agree with that I said I
was agree with louis c.k that men are
the number one threat to women men are
the number one cause of injury and
mayhem to women and men are the worst
thing that ever happens to women yeah
but you can say that right back to about
women to men
no one can [ __ ] destroy a man's life
like a woman look at all of these
[ __ ] powerful men who ascend the
[ __ ] mountaintop and what brings them
them marrying the wrong [ __ ] woman
will [ __ ] your life over worse than
cancer
anyways I do that I do not know any
woman who has not been in some way
physically and emotionally assaulted and
minimalized by men I don't know any guy
out there who's dated a [ __ ] woman
and hasn't had his hard [ __ ] stepped
on see what you're doing here sweetheart
is you're just looking out your own head
okay there's the yin and the yang okay I
don't know I've never seen a happier
woman out there than when she actually
meets a great man and vice versa
there's there's a positive way to look
at this and in this age where they just
constantly trashing men and we can just
hashtag white male trash which is you're
combining racism and sexism and you're
being called a [ __ ] hero about it I
don't get it
unless you're just gonna fight fire with
fire I don't know so anyways I would
like to teach my daughters to defend
themselves from physical aggression and
belittling comments from men now this I
agree with ya it's called [ __ ] MMA
get your kid involved in Miss mixed
martial arts get your kid involved in
sports a big believer in that however I
do know do not want to make them biased
against men as I want to raise confident
polite women who view men as their equal
but no one to defend themselves when
necessary
well I got to be honest with you
if you look at the millennial generation
they've turned Manhattan into Bed Bath &
Beyond the vibe I mean older generations
literally turned it into a giant Bed
Bath and Beyond but like I mean I never
thought I'd say this but I feel like the
stand-up scene is better in LA than it
is in New York just as far as the grown
factor I get way more groans in New York
City it's unreal anyways you had a
dollar recently and I would love to know
your opinion on what you will say to
your daughter about defending themselves
without making them psychotic or biased
against men because of the news the me2
movement the wage gap of my own personal
experiences unfortunately I find myself
more and more enraged with the opposite
sex
yeah that's because you're just being
inundated with these [ __ ] images it's
also why you probably think everybody in
the Middle East is a [ __ ] terrorist
because that's all they're showing you
know social media is a massive failure
and there's all these studies coming out
now that show that it actually it you
know it makes you angry it makes you
depressed it's not a good thing anyways
and I certainly do not want to pass that
on to my daughter under any
circumstances I have talked to my
husband a little bit about this but I do
not want to tell him the extent of my
disappointment and the male species
because I plan to stay with them for the
rest of my life I would love to know
your opinion and especially your
defensive men so that I have a different
point of view anymore but balanced
opinion of men that I can pass on to my
daughter when I grow up
thank you very much PS I am from Spain
and I apologize for any grammatical or
spelling errors as my English is not my
native language well first of all
like the way that you wrote all of this
and just sitting there tree didn't say
one good [ __ ] thing that men do and
now even thrashing men to the level that
you do you're still playing the victim
here and I have to sit here and do some
tap-dance for you to try to figure out
why your [ __ ] life is actually also
great because of men go [ __ ] yourself
it's not my job to not make you with
sexist [ __ ]
alright I get it you hate men what am I
gonna do evidently you don't like
central air conditioning he all modes of
transportation modern medicine [ __ ]
some of the greatest music ever produced
I mean we have done some good things out
there Jesus Christ a couple of flashes
and a few thousand [ __ ] wars and all
of a sudden all your good deeds are just
gone I don't know what to tell you all I
can tell you is I feel bad for your
daughter and I feel really bad for your
husband that you basically don't like
men I gotta be honest as much as I trash
women I realize that most of my [ __ ] is
fear-based
because I grew up with a bunch of Pete
man that feared women and and then I
also got into this business where most
of us get divorced and I watched so much
[ __ ] go down that is really [ __ ] up
and it's just everybody just looks the
other way but having said that the older
I get the more I realize how wrong I was
about women all right having said that
now I'm not walking down the street not
having my guard up either you know I
have a big believer is you should let if
you're a nice person if you're a good
person you have to let people earn
the fact that you're a nice person you
just don't give that away because when
you're a really nice person who's
open-minded you become a psycho magnet
and some of the worst people ever are
gonna really gonna come into your life
because they need someone is nice and is
forgiving because everybody else is not
gonna put up with that [ __ ] but a
lot of [ __ ] that I've said about women
has been 100% in the wrong and I
understand that so I don't know you kind
of sound like where you where I was at
about ten years ago
with the opposite sex and you're also
kind of making yourself out to be a hero
I don't know I don't know when I see
guys on stage trashing men like that I
always just think they're just trying to
get laid you know what I mean this whole
[ __ ] thing that all man down there's
been done that yeah they have we also
done a lot of great things too we also
have done a lot of great [ __ ] thanks
- okay and at the end of the day to
always be talking about women as victims
and in these victim positions is not
empowering to women all right to just
sit around and just say all of my
problems are because of a male-dominated
society like where is that gonna get and
then your solution is to just [ __ ]
about men and then hashtag white male
trash as white male trash here I can
tell you we're not having any meetings
concerned about any of that [ __ ]
you're just [ __ ] talking to other
women that believe the same way you do
okay in life if you want to get out of
your situation you have to [ __ ] take
control of it
all right if you don't like working from
men start your own thing all right I
don't like working for other people
that's why I do this and this is why I
do stand-up and will continue to do that
so you always have to have that ability
to be like well that's the deal you're
offering me
yeah I don't want it go [ __ ] yourself
and you walk away so what would you do
for your daughter
I would first of all I would not give
her probably 90% of your negative
opinions on men because she'll become a
man hater but it's your kid if that's
what you want and I would I don't know
if I was running [ __ ] I would secretly
teach every woman out there mix martial
arts and and then that Israeli [ __ ]
martial art [ __ ] we disarm people that
have weapons you know that thing where
they got a gun in your face and you that
little flat moving all of a sudden
you're holding the gun pointing it at
them
yeah that type of [ __ ] I would also tell
your daughter to never go back to a
hotel room but the guy ever ever ever
guys do not want to talk to you if guys
want to talk and we go hang out with the
fellas okay they're trying to [ __ ] you
that's it and we a let's go back to
hotel room just talk that's just part of
him trying to get you back there I don't
know I feel bad for your husband it's
all I can tell you because I just
inserted myself into that things it's
like oh my god you know you didn't say
one positive thing about men and you
just wrote a giant [ __ ] there wasn't
one positive thing in there and and the
worst thing about where we're at right
now as human beings is you would be
complimented on that and you would be
called strong and that's the direction
that we're headed in you know and you
know what I don't dictate it so I don't
know I guess mixed martial arts and I
teach her how to run a business and
along the way you know if you don't know
how to do that I would learn that too so
you don't have to work for men for the
record men treat other men like [ __ ] too
by the way and that whole feminist
[ __ ] idea that if a guy's a dick that
he gets respect like is the stupidest
thing ever no one likes a dick no one
wants to work for a dick and everybody
secretly hopes the guy crashes on the
[ __ ] way home hey you know what I
loved about my boss he treated me like
[ __ ] and I don't know why I just really
respected him nobody likes being treated
like [ __ ] that is something a woman made
up because it fit that [ __ ] argument
and everybody ran with it yeah if you're
acting like an [ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] all right Joe Rogan is
gonna get you killed
the [ __ ] is this all right Bilborough on
the podcast 11 16 17 you said I still
can't wrap my head around the fact that
I can eat this much meat oh god here we
go here's another [ __ ] nutritionist
with no [ __ ] background whatsoever
he's not gonna tell me everything that I
watch is now [ __ ] right is that what
this is going okay because you can't
bill I know you look I I know you love
your body Joe Rogan however your buddy
the self-proclaimed conspiracy theorist
Absalom I is dead wrong about nutrition
all that meat and animal saturated facts
will line your arteries with disease
Laden plaque do not eat this stuff in
abundance minimize it forget the notion
of moderation too that's all horseshit
this is this right here this I'm telling
they're like religious nuts all of it is
horseshit explain the French then in
their rich diet and their lack of
[ __ ] heart disease over there
listen there's elements of truth and
everything and the second you're gonna
sit there and tell me that your diet is
the diet it's all horseshit the bulk of
your cattle calories should be from
beans peas and legumes vegetables fruits
nuts and seeds and whole grains crush
waters and eat your salads as per usual
of course but add walnuts pumpkin seeds
blueberries mushrooms potatoes sweet
potatoes and greens to your daily
routine as well as countless other Whole
Foods of your choice minimalize all oils
Pro processed foods
who doesn't know about processed foods
meats dairy and eggs
I don't care where the [ __ ] they come
from like Rogen's elk from the mountains
of gods or wherever the [ __ ] he hunts go
to nutritionfacts.org now did you vet
nutritionfacts.org do you know where
this came from for all published
nutritional science in all the esteemed
peer review world worldwide were
reviewed worldwide medical journals and
science papers yeah buddy they have
blood money behind them okay I'm not
saying it's all [ __ ] but there is an
element of [ __ ] in there the food
industry [ __ ] wines those people's
pockets he said forget the nonsense from
the media advertising and the
pseudoscience pushing fruitcakes like
Rogen I know he mean well he means well
but he's wrong look at the works of dr.
joel Fuhrman dr. Michael Greger dr. John
McDougall dr. Dean Ornish dr. Cardwell I
can't read this guy's name alistun and
others just looking out for your buddy
hey tell you what thanks for looking out
for me I'm gonna do what the [ __ ] I've
been doing anyways because I have low
blood pressure
you know I'm doing fine and I'm keeping
the weight off alright I'm not gonna
just sit there eating two handfuls of
[ __ ] bacon alright but uh you know
and I'm also not gonna just eat a
plant-based diet I'm not doing that I'm
gonna continue to do what the [ __ ] I'm
doing cuz it's working for me and with
all due respect sir and no point there
did you say you are any sort of
nutritionist you just read a bunch of
[ __ ] that made sense to you alright and
then you also went to like you went to
like the the mainstream [ __ ] thing
and that mainstream thing has a bunch of
money behind it okay from people in the
food [ __ ] industry that want to sell
the food that they grow so that place is
also naturally perverted or corrupt I'm
not saying it's all [ __ ] but there
is an element of bull
[ __ ] would you not agree in that there's
elements of [ __ ] and every [ __ ]
thing including this goddamn podcast so
don't listen to me either
all right here's the last one here
accidentally killed girlfriend's cat
don't know what to do Billy showed
that's something I never found funny
that where it showed there's like a
certain portion of like part of the
country that thinks is that's a funny
[ __ ] word which I believe is like a
short fat dick got myself into a little
bit of a moral dilemma I'd appreciate
some advice my girlfriend of seven
months seven months has an outdoor cat
who was really smart and could always
find her way back home anyways you can
probably see where this is going where I
can see where it's going in the title he
said he accidentally killed your
girlfriend's cat I'm driving to her
place less than a block away not really
watching the road and I hit the [ __ ]
thing died on impact practically in two
pieces
hey week that's all we can all pray for
huh a quick death I hit the [ __ ]
thing alright but my girl had this cat
for some four years and has a serious
emotional attachment I'm not trying to
be the [ __ ] who killed her cat so I
had a couple of sturdy plastic bags in
my car a towel in a water bottle sounds
like he just came from the gym in a
7-eleven and without getting into the
gritty details within 10 minutes looked
like nothing ever happened I chucked it
into a dumpster a few blocks away Oh God
get get a car wash to be extra cautious
and drive back to her place so it's been
two weeks and I haven't told her she's
freaking posted at least thirty missing
cat photos all around the neighborhood
and anywhere even remotely nearby
[ __ ] crying and all of that [ __ ] it's
messing with my conscious and our sex
life there's there you go there you go
you selfish bastard
I feel like if she knows it's dead zou
she'll be able to move on but also with
me covering it up for so long I'd be in
a good bit of trouble so to say the
least help me out here on what I should
do
yeah do the the SS coming clean that
ships sailed that ship sailed right
after you cleaned up the crime scene and
threw it in a [ __ ] dumpster here's
what you do you don't say a [ __ ] word
you don't say a [ __ ] word it's over
dude it's over there's no do you let her
cry for two [ __ ] weeks and you know
that it's over and then I'll see you
after you got to ask yourself am I going
to marry this person all right here's
the deal
if you're gonna marry this person don't
ever [ __ ] tell her all right if you
don't want to marry this person you got
to do what you got to do a two-for-one
here all right you have to break up with
her and then also tell her that you
killed her cat but not in that order you
tell her that you killed her cat all
right
and then hopefully she'll break up with
you oh wait you open with killing or cat
I'll do this just know I don't know if
yeah this is around the holidays I think
you got to do it look if you want to
stay with her if you love her are you
gonna marry this woman if you're gonna
marry this woman
don't tell her you killed a cat if
you're not gonna marry your woman and I
you know I don't know I know there's a
lot of people also horrified by this
[ __ ] story but like I mean the cat
was dead well we supposed to do here
Amy should have told it but I mean as
far as like throwing the thing in the
dumpster I mean if I die in somebody
throws me in a dumpster I don't give a
[ __ ] my biggest concern is how bad I'm
going to smell up that parking lot
other than that I'm dead
don't need some fancy [ __ ] box you
know I don't understand that when people
die and they put them in these these
beautiful [ __ ] caskets it's like it's
a piece of fruit that went bad you know
and you're putting it on display throw
it in the [ __ ] trash
all right that's disgusting okay that's
the end of the podcast here happy
Thanksgiving everybody do your cardio
eat your salads go nuts on Thanksgiving
but hit it again right on Friday all
right
get after it I wish I could actually
meet that woman from Spain and we could
sit down and talk about all my [ __ ]
women hate and [ __ ] and she could talk
about our guy hate and [ __ ] maybe we
could [ __ ] find a middle ground
before we both [ __ ] up our daughters
no I would never say anything negative
about women to my daughter I would all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves happy
turkey day and I'll check in on you on
Thanksgiving look at that not even
taking a day off all right I'll see